for the marlins it's braxton garrett his
seventh start of this season in his
eighth game coming off that rough outing
against the padres
three straight walks brings up austin
riley a 2-2
and a swing and a miss
goes to the slider and gets austin
reilly for
a pretty big out number one that man of
course brave shortstop dansby swanson
dansby
race to the second base bag and dansby
beats it at first a run is going to
score
bang bang play at second jazz chisholm
got to the bag
was freeman rung up at the moment it's
one nothing the braves going to
challenge the outcall at second base
adam duval the hitter the former marlin
you figure he knows these guys very well
and duvall skies one out towards shallow
center
diaz will
make the catch
and the challenge is on for tooky
toussaint hometown kid pitching against
a marlins team against which he's had a
lot of success
and that is jazz chisholm jr hitting one
deep into the second deck for the second
day in a row
lead off home run jazz chisholm jr now
they want that ball down the sinker we
didn't even get to the arsenal but it
was left up and jazz who yesterday
unloaded big time
does it again to start the ball game
with two two-way here's e-san diaz
nissan smokes one oh
boy
that's over the bullpen and right
eastside diaz goes deep
and the marlins take a 2-1 lead
sinker location missed
nissan didn't miss it
it's another walk that is four of them
for garrett two on nobody out and dansby
swan senior hitter still manageable 2-1
score
and dansby smacks that towards center
but right at brinson
and no advance for freddie freeman
dansby hit it hard but he's retired for
route number one
duvall line drive to short
two outs see if darno gets something fat
pitch
on the ground but right to chisholm goes
the short way in atlanta one for ten
with runners in scoring position they're
down a run in the middle of the third
inning
well the fourth inning starting like the
first inning began jeff when the braves
got three consecutive bases on balls and
scored but one run
and now it's paul campbell
on to pitch two on nobody out one strike
for albies
he's betting left-handed now and he
shoots that one into right center field
that's down for a base hit they are
going to wave haredi around here comes
the throw to the plate it's gonna be
late ozzy obese has another rbi his 81st
of the year and just like that atlanta
has tied the game and they're still
first and second with nobody out freddy
freeman's walked and singled
freddy unloads deep to right field that
ball is gone
freeman just reeled him in got to a 3-1
count and the homer-hitting braves do it
again a three-run shot for freeman he's
got 68 rbis and the braves have a 5-2
lead
now riley tries to gap one he's going to
that's going to one hop off the fence
all of a sudden the hitting's gotten
contagious for the braves that is their
third hit of this inning
and now dansby rips one toward the gap
that's down for a hit riley chugging
around third he's going to score without
a play dansby swanson has his second rbi
of the night
here's adam duvall
and now duvall got a hanger and look how
far that one's going
way out that's as far as they go out on
the concourse
adam duvall has hit his 27th home run
his fifth with the braves
and the offense is in high gear all of a
sudden it is eight to two and wash is
loving it and that was a no doubter 400
45 feet he has
six to play with as he has to get
through this fifth jeff qualify for the
win
this one on the ground but in the shift
riley's got it toussaint racking them up
79 pitches for tukey through five
innings it's eight two braves the braves
haven't been second and third one out or
the top of the order again
2-2 pitch
ozzy on the ground off the glove of jazz
chisholm and that's gonna score two more
ozzy albies does pick up a couple more
rbis that's
82 and 83 and atlanta cashes in two more
walks as tukey toussaint has set down
seven straight
as a swing and a miss takes care of
aguilar that's six strikeouts for tukey
he's retired eight straight
winding the pitch fly ball to right
field a little off the end of the bat
solar is there he's got it two down
graves trying to pick up a half game on
the phillies and toussaint just mowed
him down
was that tipped
sanchez is retired on a swing and a miss
the back swing gets darno 10 up 10 down
seven strikeouts for tukey toussaint
10-2 atlanta top of the seventh if
dansby doesn't read that'd be the first
inning of the ball game the braves
didn't have at least one man reach
broken bat rolled toward chisholm tricky
hop almost stumbled through to first and
they got him dansby says check it out
boy you love the fact in a 10-2 game
braves are still busting down the line
safer out
oh he's safe absolutely
and they're gonna go check it look
you can sit here and say oh you want to
know what some people i'm sure the
marlins it's ten two
look you hustle like that you wanna you
wanna hit and so this one is going to be
overturned dansby does have a second hit
as there it is walk number 10 it comes
with two outs
for 10 more runs tonight and darneau
cracks that at the gap in right center
field that's going to get down for a hit
dansby swanson will gallop home duvall
on his way to third they're going to
send him no throw from isan diaz and
travis starneaux adds on for atlanta it
is 12-2
he had a double down the right field
line to start the night
that sounds so great double the right
center gap to drive into
jacob webb
coming in to get the final three outs of
this first game blowout against the
marlins
sierra to center already has got it and
the braves add to their eastern division
lead they pick up a half game over the
idol phillies big night for adam duvall
who returns to his former home he hits a
445 foot homer
you